can't believe we're about to have to
talk about this senator warren now
believes that not only are beef
producers and energy producers price
gouging and using their monopolistic
powers to go ahead and take advantage of
the little guy but now she has turned
her attention to go after grocery stores
literally she is going after grocery
stores she tweeted earlier and said
giant grocery store chains force high
food prices onto american families while
rewarding executives and investors with
lavish bonuses and stock buybacks i'm
demanding the answer for putting
corporate profits over consumers and
workers during the pandemic now the
first thing i would like to call out is
that grocery stores are not sitting
there saying
let's just jack up the price because it
would be fun they didn't randomly decide
in 2021 this is the year we're gonna
gouge them watch out
no
of course the grocery store's expenses
are increasing the cost of food is going
up the cost of transportation is going
up the money that they pay their workers
is going up there's a recent report in
the washington post that now
officially the national average
pay per hour for grocery store workers
across america is 15 an hour that's
right the grocery stores were able to
accomplish an average 15 an hour pay for
their employees before politicians like
senator warren were able to actually get
it done legislatively so the grocery
stores have done more for workers than
the politicians because they're actually
paying them 15 an hour on top of that
obviously food costs are going up and
transportation costs as well if the
grocery stores were
actually monopolies if they actually
wanted to price couch why didn't they do
it last year during the pandemic or in
2019 or in 2018 or 2017 or 2016 or 2015.
why is it that today they just randomly
woke up and said we're gonna price gouge
of course it's because they're not
actually price gouging they simply are
taking their increased cost and they're
passing it on to the consumer now that's
how business works is if my costs go up
i still need to be able to make a profit
and this isn't some sort of high margin
business it's actually a razor thin
margin business and so our good friend
bobby goodlatte he had a nice little
response to senator warren he said those
evil grocers and their checks notes 1.75
profit margins literally
if inflation
of
if inflation goes up seven percent or so
then the entire profit margin of the
grocery store if they do not increase
their prices disappears they begin to
lose money is that what the politicians
are advocating for is for our private
businesses to intentionally lose money
that doesn't make a lot of sense
on top of that food both in the home and
outside the home are up four or five
percent year over year so it's not just
the grocery stores it's also restaurants
and other places where we consume food
everywhere things are getting more
expensive and so if grocery stores do
not increase their prices they won't be
able to pay their employees they won't
be able to actually supply food to their
local communities because they'll be out
of business but of course people who
have never run a business before don't
understand this and so if you don't
believe bobby or me let's just go look
at the actual profit margins fact check
kroger's operating margin for the first
nine months of this year
was 2.4
which was less than the 2.9 a year ago
kroger's making less money on a profit
margin basis so not only are they not
price gouging not only are they not
paying lavish bonuses and making all
this corporate profit
kroger's making less money in 2021 than
they were in 2020. this is complete
nonsense
and the politicians know it but that's
not it if you go ahead and you actually
look and dig a little bit deeper what
you can see here is that it's very clear
they're making less money even though
the grocery stores are actually
increasing their prices they make less
money now i don't believe that senator
warren or anybody else actually believes
the nonsense that they're saying there's
people on both sides of the political
aisle that are saying all kinds of crazy
stuff around inflation but at the end of
the day what we have is we have
businesses that are paying their
employees more and they're making less
profit
on top of that they are having to
increase prices to accommodate for the
higher labor cost and also the higher
cost of goods and transportation
and so naturally whether we like it or
not that is how capitalism works is that
people will increase their prices in
order to pass off the cost to consumer
now if this was some sort of super
egregious highly profitable business
where they still had 100 200 300 margins
then of course we could be upset
but that's not what this is this is a
razor thin margin business where people
are literally just trying to make a
couple of cents per item
if you go to the store and you buy
something for one dollar
they make two pennies
based on their profit margin that's it
97 and a half percent
of that dollar you pay
is cost
it's not a very good business
unless you can be operationally
efficient and you can barely eke out
those profit margins
now on top of all of this
of course politicians understand the
internet they know if they yell and
scream if they claim that these people
are bad actors they'll trick the
uneducated they'll trick the people who
aren't paying attention
i don't see
anywhere where people are saying yup i
checked the numbers i'm informed i
looked at the data and they're right
ultimately at the end of the day it
comes down to one simple thing
people are going to try to run their
businesses and make money because that
is the point of running a business and
unfortunately because we have
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
that is only going to get worse and
worse and worse until politicians stop
screwing around and start actually
trying to run a balanced budget not
increasing the debt limit by trillions
of dollars and not spending our taxpayer
money as if it was
not theirs because ultimately what we
have is a spending problem in this
country and we have undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy
and then they yell and they scream at
the very people who are simply trying to
provide jobs and trying to feed their
local communities